s stands for advancement of blacks and
sports it's an organization that is
proudly one of the voices of racial
equity in sports and after all the work
they do year round it is time to
celebrate this memorial day weekend so
let's welcome ceo and founder of abis
gary charles to the show welcome hey
how are you i'm good good now we're on
the same page we're matching yeah i
didn't notice that okay okay so this is
that's a good thing that's a good thing
we're on the same page because we're
working together this weekend
but before we talk about champions and
legends weekend let's talk about abis
and just what your mission is well we
want to be um the voice for racial
equity in sports you know that's when it
comes down to that's that's what it is i
think too many people have been hurt in
the sports world as far as in our
community
and we want to stop that so we want to
be that voice for it the naacp of sports
oh i like that i like that and of course
helping blacks and sports but also
celebrating them so let's get to the
weekend memorial day weekend what's on
the lineup explain what we're
celebrating well we're celebrating us i
felt that there's no reason for us to
have to wait for someone else to tell us
how we should celebrate and how we
should let people know the things that
we've done amen so
this weekend is going to be the
culmination of people that people need
to recognize and understand what they've
done in our community absolutely and one
of the board members for abis is nikki
fargus of the aces president of the aces
why is vegas the perfect place to bring
this event you know what i've been
coming to vegas since 1991
with my own basketball new york if you
couldn't tell
i have no idea what you're talking about
but that's another story
but
so
been coming here this whole time i felt
that vegas was the exact spot to go
ahead and put something on like this and
one of our other members
on the board dave lato
the former coaching university of
virginia and depauw university
he also thought this was a the right
spot to make this happen and then with
nikki being here yeah and being a board
member oh he was just all aligning at
the right time absolutely the greatest
arena on earth is the perfect place for
this event and um who are we honoring on
saturday for the gala the epic awards
gala this is your first annual and
myself my tv neighbor brian salmon will
be emceeing the event so what can we
expect
there's a couple things that we're doing
one is that
we are naming certain awards after
certain people and then people are going
to receive those particular awards okay
for example we had the jacket join the
courtesy excellence award awesome and
allison felix is going to be receiving
that one
we have the shaquille o'neal economic
and sustainability award okay and that's
going to go to albert king
we have the vivian stringer pioneer
award that's going to go to dawn staley
but also we also want to recognize
allies so we have the sunny vaquel
champion of change award and that's
going to go to former miami coach brian
flores who's now with the steelers
because you know giving up your career
like that right that changes yeah okay
so he's he's going to earn that okay
he's earned that uh dr j dr j
doctor that's going to be receiving a
lifetime achievement award okay
then how about we have the william c
rhoden sports media award that's going
to go to jameel hill beautiful one of my
one of my someone that i look up to okay
we got a wrap now so how can people get
tickets because there's still tickets
available for friday's events saturdays
events and sunday's events it's an
entire weekend
please go to abis
champion legends
dot eventbrite.com
all right all right please show up
support so you can stay here in vegas
all right stay here thank you so much
charles gary excuse me gary charles
thank you so much here the apis
champions and legends weekend starts
tomorrow and goes through sunday join us
at their first awards gala saturday
evening where i'll be emceeing for more
information just head to abis.org and
for any tickets you want to get as well
you can get you can get them there too
we'll be back